okay so we have the second episode of
the second season the cave of two lovers
and you know this is one I would not
describe as a filler episode and lay
explain something real fast cuz a lot of
people are like oh no it's come on this
episode's coming back later or these
little elements are coming back later um
when I say filler episode I'm not
meaning first I'm not meaning waste of
time filler episodes can be fine because
if you what filler episodes do they
allow you to not focus entirely in the
story and instead focus on elements that
might seem minor but er important
elements of character elements of
environment that's not necessarily
furthering furthering the story maybe a
little element is but you know that may
come in later which a lot of them do but
for the most part focusing on letting
the characters and the environment
breathe uh which I am all for you know
something like a lot Christopher Nolan
works I think picky and alone a lot
recently upon ties but he's just an easy
example um are very much story folk is
you know an exposition you know a story
story story story exposition exposition
I feel something oh well story story
story exposition exposition speech
speech speech and is something like
avatar is a much better balance because
they can take those episodes to just let
the characters be a character or let
environment be an environment let you
explore it what let it feel real without
having to go story story story story so
I'm fine with that
now that's it anyway I don't necessarily
see this as a filler episode where we're
a lot probably could um first of all we
get a lot with with Zuko and the uncle
again which I mean you can't have a
filler episode after the last one I mean
the last one just so much happened um so
we got establishing what they're going
to do now because that's a good question
whatever they can to inhabit their
leaving the fire nation and then we also
have a growing the relationship between
Aang and Katara which I thought was
having much nicer here than in the past
which is not say was handled badly but
it could been handled better and I like
the way they're doing the this is where
they get they get caught in the cave
with these for lack of a better term
hippies they're obviously trying to
satirize hippies uh
I thought the hippies were funny I can
see people finding them annoying I don't
know what the general uh outlook on them
is and I I can definitely see people
being like oh my god I hope I never see
these characters again but I thought
they're pretty funny maybe for kind of
my dislike of some hippies um but
there's nice hippies - but just someone
can be annoying
um and pretty much what I'll talk about
the cave part first you know I like this
backstory of the cave is essentially
Romeo and Juliet but with a few nice
twist to sort of make it their own story
I like the like going out and seeing the
the however they did that the crystals
on top I thought that was very clever
again creates a its own unique thing
because I don't think there's a crystals
out there that will shine in the dark
complete darkness and that's a good
riddle too because who would want to go
completely in the dark you know it's
very smart out I like that I like when
they do the backstories - they do those
I mean this looks like watercolor I
think it was uh I like that the show
does stuff with that that it does things
so not traditional particularly in kid
shows and I really like that and they
they don't do it just because it's
different they do it because it really
ties in and it really creates the
environment so I'm a big fan of that uh
also ie even though there's a little bit
of sort of the typical romantic comedy
elements in there like I enjoy when she
says maybe we should kiss maybe that's
what they're talking about she's
blushing
of course Aang's gonna say the wrong
thing and she's gonna take it a
different way and they're gonna whew to
bid it you know I'm not a fan of that
but they get past it very quickly uh but
what I really enjoy is that they
actually did show it was a genuinely
romantic moment when you know even if
it's between two kids when the light is
dimming for all they know this could be
the last time they could see each other
and I like the way they did as the light
got darker and darker they got closer
and closer and it's the first for me it
anyway it's the first really romantic
kiss where you never
the kiss you don't even see the outline
or the silhouette it goes totally black
very effective and very romantic I think
a lot of people think oh he's he doesn't
like romance or a the typical guy like
romance is great if efforts put into and
I think that was such a cleverly staged
uh and well paced moment again but
anyway for a kid show so I was really
impressed with how they pull that off um
so I like that and I like the humor with
the hippies I thought was good the humor
with Sokka interacting with the hippies
lets me as that's where a lot of comedy
is coming from I love the way to get
that mark on the head and when the one
hit pieces I don't like it out but I
think that kids the avatar knee smacks
the guy vide that's great that's really
good physical humor right there good
visual humor um so that was good but the
other element I found very interesting
is the air story going on with uh Zuko
and the uncle trying to figure out what
they're gonna do next I question a
little bit that we'll see where it goes
my question a little bit that nobody
would be able to point out but show the
old man and a kid with almost no hair
and a giant scarred eye in the shape of
one of Rio's fireballs I mean this
should be the easiest person to point
out and find it used to be Prince of the
enemy of the world
it's like start trying to find Hitler
you could probably locate him pretty
easily but um so kid show you know
that's that's nitpicking yeah let it
slide um so you got them they come
across this family uh I think it was in
the earth bending nation I think I'm not
sure uh they got a little bit comedy
with that again with the uncle um I love
how he eats this flower it's either
something really good or poisonous it
turns out it's poisonous but still very
relaxed about in a few hours my neck
will swell up and I won't be able to
breathe but luckily I found these
berries oh wait do these kill you or
make you better at it's at I love how
laid-back he is even on the most extreme
thing
um particularly with his life but maybe
that's what I like about it I like that
more about sort of his life and his need
to relax its need to help others relax
you know but when others are put in
jeopardy then he'll sort of you know
like when the moon was being friend
he'll be he'll step off so as I like
that but what I really enjoy is they
find this family particularly this one
girl who also lost her father also is
scarred and they give them shelter they
give them food they treat them they
treat the scars and the burns or the the
swelling that the uncle has and they
talk and they share and Zuko is
obviously still very hurt by what's
happened but he does listen and you
think you know where it's gonna go well
Zuko's outlook on everything is totally
gonna change he's gonna do something
nice for them or he's gonna realize
something no they steal the horse or
whatever that was that they steal it and
even the uncle who doesn't like doing it
agrees to do it too because they are
outlaws and they're still you know their
background they came from a world that
is looking to take over everything and
mercy is weak and so on so forth and
they need to survive so I really really
like that it didn't end on a happy note
necessarily and zuko was not even that
apologetic you could tell me he felt a
twinge bad but I mean he could use his
fire and been like you know aha suckers
and steal the horse but no they do it
quietly in the night and I also like
that the girl sees it she sees them
steal the horse and just sort of looks
Sheamus the door it's a very I mean
that's the word I think I'm looking for
that any is just you feel ashamed to
watch it that these people are so nice
and they still steal that way and they
both feel like they don't have a choice
and it's okay it was very adult um you
don't even see that in too much adult
stuff I mean at least not you know
blockbusters or anything like that so I
really that that was really good as a
very bittersweet feeling uh leaving even
more to
it's the bitter really so I like it
because it doesn't make as obvious what
direction he's going to go oh where
they're gonna go um obviously they're no
the fire nation anymore but I can go
find the avatar or they you think maybe
they're gonna fight against the Fire
Nation help everyone else but now they
still sir have this philosophy this is
philosophy they've been raised with for
years so I really enjoy that I thought
that was a really a very good mix of
that um so yeah so you got an episode
really of people connecting relating off
each other you got Aang and Katara you
got the uncle and the Zuko and then you
also have even Sokka and the hippies you
know he's annoyed by them but at the
same time they do sort of learn a little
bit off each other not much but a little
bit uh and on top of that at the end it
quickly brings it back to the story
where they get to the giant the Minas
Tirith City I always call it and they
find it's been taken over by the Fire
Nation and that's a that's a good area
to leave it I guess just like oh no
about the crazy leaf-eating king Swiper
more than most about that eating that we
feel so weird oh but nevertheless so
it's a good to be continued at you know
you sort of like that even if you did
sort of think this was a filler episode
like up now we're coming back we're
bringing it back uh so I get really good
episode and a good follow up to such a
strong start hi in that last one so yeah
very much enjoy it again you probably
heard me say that a lot but it's a good
episode it's another good episode and I
look forward to the next one see you
there